my wrists stop washing my neck is fussy
make big deposits my gloves is popping
you like my hair she thanks just bought
it i see it i like it i want it i got it
kelly clarkson is giving fans another
epic kalioke performance it was amazing
the 39-year-old singer performed a cover
of ariana grande's hit song seven rings
on her daytime talk show the kelly
clarkson show on friday
and there's no doubt her fellow voice
coach is proud
[Music]
[Music]
yep that's kelly nailing those fast and
tricky lyrics
[Music]
but this is just one of the latest
kellyary crossover performances in
recent weeks for the american idol alums
when christmas comes around special the
two superstars performed their new
holiday duet santa can't you hear me for
the first time together
[Music]
kelly and ariana also sang each other's
songs on jimmy fallon's new show that's
my jam
[Applause]
the ladies teamed up with their fellow
voice coaches blake shelton and john
legend for a segment called slay it
don't spray it
[Applause]
and let's just say ari was slaying
kelly's song stronger until she couldn't
remember the lyrics
[Applause]
[Music]
is
it's no surprise that we're seeing so
many collabs between all the coaches
when the four singers spoke to e.t ahead
of the season 21 premiere ariana shared
how excited she was to be joining the
team i was a huge fan of the voice i
have watched many seasons and i love
watching the show it always has the best
energy and it's just such like wholesome
inspiring television and i love seeing
the different voices and watching so
many people start careers for themselves
it's like a beautiful amazing thing and
i've always been a fan but i also got to
sing on the show a couple of times and
that was really cool
as well
um
and yeah so now i'm here and it's very
amazing and i feel so grateful to be
here it's just being new there's so much
to learn but i
feel like i just get to learn watching
them and it's been amazing